it's sort of like the first time you
were to go swimming
in a pool that's not really cold but
it's a little bit cool you jump in and
but if you do that every day you jump in
and go it's actually not that cold i'm
just going to jump in and it becomes a
non-event but when you first do it like
the water was only 72 degrees what am i
going to do and meanwhile you've got
michael's phelps swimming in 36 degree
water you know totally different area
i'm just saying mild discomfort
and
what i do in fastest ways i teach people
look
you have a job probably you're possibly
a parent and there's lots going on in
your life
fasting is a spiritual discipline when
you want to do a spiritual fast and
fasting is a high performance working
thing when you do it for performance
because when your body is busy chewing
up whatever foods in your gut it's not
using that energy to think or recover
it's actually using it to make more
energy so then you wake up in the
morning and say i don't want to feel
that discomfort nobody does and it's
okay you don't have to suffer too fast
so then there's three things you can do
in the morning that completely remove
the pain of fasting but allow your body
to still get the fasting benefits and
that's what you would start with
so that then you don't feel like you're
going to die the discomfort isn't there
and
you're sort of saying this was the best
morning i had because i never thought
about food and like everyone can fast if
you don't think about food right right
exactly so what are those three things
okay
um the lowest level one is just black
coffee
and the reason black coffee works and
yes i did start a coffee company i'm not
running it anymore
bulletproof but the reason i'm talking
about black coffee is studies from uc
san diego show that just the amount of
caffeine in two small cups of coffee
doubles your production of ketones
when you're doing even a short
intermittent fast if you can get ketones
up a little bit ketones turn on a
hormone that makes you feel full and
they turn off the hunger hormone ghrelin
is the hunger hormone and cck is the
fullness hormone which is made by calvin
klein
not really
i'm kind of a nerd
so
when you do that okay black coffee
suddenly it was a lot easier and people
know coffee suppresses hunger but no
sugar and especially no artificial
sweeteners in the coffee because that
breaks your gut bacteria any of them
it's stevia you name it you should be
okay with stevia or monk fruit
but you're not gonna be okay with
sucralose and aspartame and all those
chemical ones those really are shown to
cause harm especially for weight loss
and then the second one is you can do a
bulletproof coffee which is grass-fed
butter and that mct oil blended in and
when you do that something happens to
the water that's in the coffee so that
your body can more easily use that water
even inside the brain
and it adds extra energy but because
it's got only fat your body says oh
there was no sugar there was no protein
all of the hormones of fasting stay low
so you actually got some energy
but all of your hunger is now turned off
you're like i just don't care about food
and i have tons of energy meanwhile your
body says i didn't have to digest
anything
you're still fasting and so all the
fasting benefits happen but you're
relaxed
and the third thing that you can add
either to water or to coffee or tea
whatever is prebiotic fiber and this is
fiber that does not raise your blood
sugar it has a very neutral flavor and
so there's no one on earth i've ever met
who can't put enough of this very
healthy fiber that feeds your good gut
bacteria in with some butter and some
mct and some coffee you blend it up and
you drink that you're thinking i am so
not interested in food right now but the
body says i didn't get any sugar i
didn't get any protein therefore i'm
going to be in fat burning mode and i'm
going to do the benefits of fasting
tomorrow morning if you do this danica
you will simply not care about food and
when lunch time comes
you're going to say i guess i could eat
and it's going to be so liberating you
wouldn't even believe it prebiotic fiber
first off because i've seen a couple of
products and actually bought one the
other day because i'm doing all kinds of
testing all kinds of gut health rese all
kinds of all kinds of things going on
which is fascinating stuff and
um i've i've been diving in pretty deep
but it always has a carbohydrate is that
correct or at least the one that i found
and the ones that i've seen it always
seems like a prebiotic has
has as a carbohydrate base is that true
prebiotics are always made out of
carbohydrates
and that's okay though because we have
these
stories that became a part of our our
cultural
our cultural view like we have to get
our macros or how about this one
protein's good for you or better
plant-based protein is good for you
right right oh i've gone round and round
about all that too
didn't everybody try vegan for a minute
it made me really sick i did not enjoy
it either
but here's the funny thing my favorite
plant-based protein is sarin the nerve
gas that was used in the tokyo it comes
from beans
so
not all proteins are good for you and
not all plant proteins are good for you
by the way don't eat spider venom which
is an animal protein so
they're going wait like a good idea
maybe different proteins do different
things maybe different carbohydrates do
different things too got it got it and
right and the cool thing with a
prebiotic fiber is that the body cannot
digest it even a little bit so from your
body's perspective it's invisible it
doesn't count as a carb just a filler
there's two sorts of fiber there's
soluble fiber which is prebiotic and
then there's coarse fiber like sawdust
and your body will feel the sawdust to a
certain point because it provides like
space but when you eat the other the the
prebiotic fiber yeah it has no flavor
and the more of it you eat the longer
you're likely to live
your gut bacteria the good guys like yes
let's have a party and they start to
replicate and as they digest it they
convert it into a short chain fat called
butyric acid that is ketogenic and is
really good for your gut and really good
for your brain
so now i'm so glad i bought this the
other day yeah exactly so it's totally
fine that has carbs in it unless it has
sugar or unless it has digestible carbs
and
this idea that prebiotics are super
filling is well
well supported by research and
this anti-aging effect by feeding your
good gut bacteria we would all live
longer if we had more than 20 grams of
soluble fiber a day and most of us don't
get that in our diet i take 60 grams a
day in other words in the morning i put
a couple scoops in my coffee and it
disappears and then i've had more fiber
than almost anyone else and
it tastes the same and then my body's
just not interested in food i remember
going down to mexico down to tulum and i
think i heard that they they believe
that there's two brains one in the
stomach and one in the brain like one up
here one down there the two brains and
one in the heart two one in the heart
yeah yeah where does collagen fit into
that because this morning what i did
actually because i was like you know
i'm gonna have so i put in some mct oil
i put in a little bit of it was a
vanilla ghee i don't know if it has to
be grass-fed butter but what i had was
vanilla ghee and regular so i used the
vanilla for fun and i put some collagen
in it so where does that fit into add
collagen is that not part of the
protocol is that a different kind of
supplementation
i am probably the world's biggest fan of
collagen and the reason cauldron is a
big rage is that 10 years ago i started
really pushing this as
we missed this and it's become you know
a commonplace ingredient before that it
was it was not used for health
and
if you are trying to lose more than say
20 pounds or your metabolism is sort of
stuck and sluggish there's a case for
having protein in your coffee for a
month so when you wake up you have
20 or ideally 40 grams of protein that'd
be four scoops of collagen
with right after you wake up and you do
that to reset your body's leptin
ingredient sensitivity but that's not
fasting that's telling your body hey
it's a circadian timing like wake up
it's time for you to learn how to
metabolize protein in fat
when you're doing intermittent fasting
collagen or any other protein will break
the fast so what i recommend people do
if you wanted to have breakfast that
morning
don't have carbs for breakfast they just
make you hungry later have carbs for
dinner so you can sleep better so in the
morning a really good amazing breakfast
is you have some butter you have some
mct you can have coffee or tea whatever
you like and you can throw collagen in
there it's in your coffee mug you're out
the door
or you can drink it at your desk but
it's really satisfying and the collagen
of course hair skin
bones joints it's it's a necessary
protein that unless you drink bone broth
or something you just don't get in the
west or you eat pig's ears like there's
weird stuff traditionally chicken feet
and pig's ears and all but i don't know
about you those aren't my normal diet
yeah let's not eat the pig's ears